Uncle Sam I want to know what you're
doing with my skin tax money what is
your door with my [ __ ] money I want
to know I want receipts I want
everything I want to know what to do
with my booty what is that to do mr.
officer more money 30 grand for a table
web and cousin loves to eat six hundred
forty dollars for the Louboutin a toilet
seat so many whips you think you were
watching Fifty Shades of Grey plus the 7
billion every year we send to TSA I
don't dance know I make Tommy's move
okay see I don't got a dance
I make Tom is me eight hundred thousand
for the homeless not the homeless monkey
drool us eighty million for a hotel but
that hotels in Kabul you say you won't
know where it go let's find out and see
caught it beat billion dollars gone
don't know where it beat it in the club
that's what happens when you give to DC
spent as much a chance to get and pay
back as Evan McMullen's vendors 40 gram
foreign actor chosen arrow
every time seen an app so overvalued
since that time I purchased miles
billions more that we give to folks we
deem a really smart or a pyramid that
tells you don't forget to eat your carbs
broke your pants and take your monitor
grope your pants and take your money to
tax code is don't worst thing scribbled
since Ben Affleck's back around this
point I figured the song is fading now
so I did not
[Music]